people
[Music]
okay and so for the last talk we have uh
first of our fellows from the databases
program
is just gonna is gonna talk about his
selector research interests
um
I was just saying
[Music]
in The Voice
you know
sorry about that
yeah
it's like
can I use a
I have my slides on the internet so yeah
if your laptop works
so it was connection over this
oh
this is the number one
so hi yeah
so hi everyone I'm Mikhail Monet and I
will talk about a few things about my
research so it's going to need to be a
mix of unrelated things hence the very
uninformative title
first let me present myself so I did my
PhD at Telecom Parry with Pierce
on combined project complexity of our
SQL evaluation and after that I did a
postdoc in Santiago in Chile with Pablo
Barcelo and since 2020 I have a research
position at India I live in France
so my main research area I would say is
uncertain data also related to
provenance and knowledge compilation I
will explain this a bit in the few
slides
so as you know data in the real life can
be often uncertain meaning that you can
have for instance missing values or we
can get data from inconsistent sources
or you can obtain data through machine
learning techniques that are not uh that
can be imperfect
and so somehow we need methods to manage
this entity instead of just ignoring it
and maybe getting a wrong or imprecise
answers
and in for relational data we have two
main models for modeling and certain
data we have probabilistic and
incomplete database I'm going to focus
on understand this probability one story
to explain what what are the
difficulties so the simplest formalism
of
for HD database is what's called a total
independent policy database and what is
that so this is just a usual relational
database with a relation stuples and so
on but it is for a stick in that every
Tuple is annotated with a probability
value which is the probability that the
data data item is uh is true and so this
defines the probability distribution on
all the possible subsets of that of the
database that we call the possible words
for instance the probability of the
possible world where we have removed the
first and the third line is going to be
given by this formula which we say we
keep a readable independently according
to its own probability
now when we have a query so this is a
simple Boolean query that usually the
answer which is just yes or no on a
usual database and hey it's not going to
be yes or no it's going to be a
probability and this value is going to
be defined by the sum of all possible
words of the of the database that
satisfy the query of the probability of
that placeable world
so obviously in general we don't want to
to do this exponential Zone because it's
uh it's too it's too big and so the
question in the area is also for which
kind of queries you can do the compute
this in polynomial time or not so for
this specific query if you think a bit
about it we'll quickly see that we can
given as input to that database like
this we can compute its answer in
polynomial time so for other queries it
is interactable so it can be sharp here
and one of the tools that we have to
compute the probability of such a query
is what is called provenance so I know
if you were there for uh the same the
similar by baltanen last last two weeks
ago but so provenance is
um of a query on a database you can say
that it is a Boolean function whose
variables are the tuples of the database
and that represent what are the
combination of tuples that can make the
query true
so for if I take again this simple
database on the same query I can express
the provenance object score on the
database as a as a propositional formula
where the the variables here they are
the tuples of the derivations here with
sequence and that we have we have to
have either Alice and Bob that apply to
inria or Alice and John or Bob and and
John
so because this is just a Boolean
function you can represent it in any way
that you want in fact yeah I can do it
in Formula or circuits or whatever
and what's interesting about about this
is that we can use this for
probabilistic evaluation for instance
so by this definition if you want to
compute the probability that the
probability database satisfies the query
if you have Computing it's provenance in
a
form so this is a brilliant function you
can then compute probability that
um the the Boolean function evaluates to
true and this is going to be exactly the
probability that the database satisfies
the query
unfortunately this isn't generally
intractable for arbitrary Boolean
Boolean functions
and so this is going to depend on how
you represent the Boolean function as
you know there are many ways of
representing Boolean functions so truth
tables proposal from the propositional
formulas in dnf or CNF binary decision
diagrams and so on so knowledge
compilation is this field that studies
uh the possible representation that you
can use to to represent Boolean
functions and what are the properties
that they should have if you want to
solve the shop set or just a
satisfiability and so on and they study
all kinds of restricted classes of
Boolean circuits with horrible names
such as dnnfs detect dnf DS dnfs and so
on sorry you know
uh yeah so that was one part of my
research
uh you can also use provenance uh not
only to do a probabilistic evaluation
you can also use it to compute what's
called a sharply values
so this if you have a fact app that is
in the database you say that the sharply
value of this fact for the query q on
the on the data database D is going to
be a value and actually is going to
represent the importance that this fact
has for the query so it's the higher
this value will be the more relevant the
the Tuple will be for to answer the to
answer your query
and so what we showed recently with uh
quarters is that if you can
compute a particular kind of circuit
that's called deterministic and
decomposable that represent the
provenance of the current database
then you can compute this sharply value
also in in polynomial time
uh similar result for another score from
machine learning
um
something else that I wanted to talk a
bit about is our hardness result and
continuing weighted matching for
mandatory growth family so this has
nothing to do about databases at all but
there will still be a bit of
probabilities so I'm interested in uh
the following problem you fix a graph
family G of J of underrated graph and
then for this graph family you define
the following problem as input you get a
graph of the graph family and
probability values of the on the edges
and what you want to compute is the
probability that you obtain a matching
of the graph when you just select or not
each agile independently
so if the graph family has bonded free
with then you can do this in a
polynomial time this is a full core
result following from core cells theorem
that you can adapt to with probabilistic
in a probabilistic setting
and what we showed with antoinemle who's
here in the room is uh we have a lower
bond that holds for any graph family
that doesn't that has that does not have
one deterries
is intractable
so this is a reduction from
uh
don't you remember the problem it's it
was a
independent setting three regular
bipartan neurons or something like the
same
uh how much how much time do I have
like three minutes okay so I will uh
I'll just keep this one
and last I wanted to talk quickly about
a cute open problem that I have which is
about perfect matchings in the Boolean
lattice
um
so I guess you all know what is a
matching in a graph but it cannot help
to recurl so matching of a graph is just
a set of edges that do not intersect and
that touch all the the vertices of the
graph
um
and so let's consider the Boolean
lattice of our K elements for instance
this one so here this is a graph and I
withdraw an edge when the this node is
included in this node and the size
difference is only one so it's really
has has a graph of the of the Boolean
lettuce
then so this is the same thing I take a
set or so this will be the orange nodes
of nodes that is upward closed in this
Boolean lattice
and I want that it have it has the
property that it has as many nodes of
even size as nodes of a size that is odd
for instance here we have a one two
three four five six nodes of uh or the
size and then we have one two three four
five six nodes of event size okay
and I'm wondering if the following is
true then for any K on a set of nodes
like this that satisfied it property
then either the orange the graph induced
by the orange nodes or that or induced
by the complement have has a perfect
matching yeah
so to have a perfect matching it has to
satisfy this condition because this is a
bipartite graph and so you want that
there are as many nodes in the two in
the two partitions of course
and so I'm wondering if this is true for
this specific example the two graphs
have a perfect matching so the orange
graph you see the perfect matching hair
in red and the complement one you see it
perfect matching in green okay
but there are graphs in which one of the
sides has no perfect matching but the
other still still has one so when this
one the orange one it does not have a
perfect matching so if you look closely
at it you can easily uh you will be
easily able to see too why it doesn't
have one but the the complementary one
has a has a perfect machine
and so I try to prove this a few maybe a
few years ago I didn't manage I I run
computer search to find a contour
example but there's no control example
so far so if you are
feel free to to think about it that's
all thank you
[Applause]
it's like okay maybe we have time for
for one question
oh okay yeah
is there a translation of this into some
property of functions or something
because presumably there's a whole
condition you want to satisfy yeah so I
tried like applying whole theorem or
Clinique uh theorem and this kind of
thing I couldn't
yeah I couldn't didn't find anything
interesting to say I said really the the
set or is uh is arbitrary just has to
satisfy this property there are one
thing I know is that if you take if you
take uh the set or that satisfies this
property but is not upward closed then
this is false I have an example where
this is false and other than that than
that I don't know much more yeah
so I tried I think all possible uh
with a five or six elements something
like that and uh
no thanks and let's thank all the
speakers again
in 20 minutes
we have one more break